mais que guerrier a grandi dans parc
extension et habite aujourd'hui
hochelaga maisonneuve montréal a beau
être multiculturelle et ouverte
elle est aussi selon lui parfois
racistes la mort de georges floride aux
états unis la secouer ça c'est la pointe
de l'iceberg
on voit pas tout ce qui est en arrière
tout l'accumulation toutes les petites
choses qui sont pas filmés toutes les
petites choses qui sont pas raconté
comptait par peur de se faire dire mais
tu joues à la victime de son enfance à
aujourd'hui il a fait face au profilage
racial comme jeune homme ou femme noire
vous aviez ce passage obligé où presque
presque un rituel d'avoir la
conversation avec nos parents comment se
comporter en présence d'un policier ou
d'une autorité qui nous accoste uem
récemment me faire suivre alors que
j'allais en studio le matin je pars à
3h30 4h du matin faire suivre par une
voiture de police
pendant quelques coins de rue qui
finalement s'arrête à côté moi pour me
dire à votre voiture farbos pourquoi moi
pourquoi ça arrive pas aux autres
pourquoi quand je parlais de mes amis
qui font partie de la majorité ils ne
vivent pas au cours de la dernière année
la commission des droits de la personne
du québec a ouvert 76 dossiers liés au
profilage racial
un rapport publié l'an dernier a
confirmé le problème à montréal ce qui
ressort nettement de ce rapport c'est
que les jeunes noirs sont susceptibles
d'être interpellé cinq fois plus que la
moyenne des jeunes québécois et les
femmes autochtones également à la fois
que je me suis fait traiter de [ __ ] je
veux dire comme ça c'est à côté de la
rue joliette
on reçoit pas de coups de fouet mais le
coût deux fois on peut le recevoir
socialement mais fait tout aussi made
des exemples mis que en a beaucoup
il se souvient de cette femme il ya
quelques années en parlant des immigrés
disaient les importer
mais pour elle c'était pas ici loge dit
que on voit le racisme comme quelque
chose de violent de deux volontaires
mais seul n'est pas toujours
parfois on peut être blessant sans s'en
rendre compte anne sara fabrice et me
dit vivre à montréal et sont dans la
jeune vingtaine avez vous l'impression
que montréal est une ville raciste ou en
tout cas plein de préjugés
je dirais qu'on est vraiment moins pire
que certaines places ailleurs dans le
monde mais c'est impossible que ça
existe pas du tout je joue il y en a
puisque mauvais sylvidra six noms mais
ce que s'il veut rempli de préjugés
je pense que oui dit je me décide de
m'habiller avec un rudy puis avoir un
chapeau quoi que ce soit j'ai beaucoup
plus de regards défiants envers moi qui
si je portais des habits un peu plus
modeste
mettons en classe il ya de quoi kiki
bayrou qui se fait voler je vais
automatiquement comme y penser comment
est-ce que le monde vont me soupçonner
ou genre je suis rendu à qom mais moi
mais je commence aussi que tu le caches
et on dirait que c'est pas normal de
vivre sorti mais ça m'ouvre quand même
les yeux serait la brutalité policière
qui dès qu'est ce que certaines
personnes race et peuvent vivre comparer
à moi moi qui rejoignent police je peux
j'ai pas peur
votre l'impression que les jeunes
d'origine arabe peuvent être aussi
ostracisé que les jeunes noirs
oui oui je veux dire toujours eu des
périodes je pense qu'il ya du racisme
plus envers les arabes par exemple
plus récemment
du racisme beaucoup envers les
asiatiques et tout mais je pense que en
ce moment est historiquement toujours ça
a été beaucoup plus les noirs c'est
vraiment comme flagrant lorsqu'on parle
de personnes d'origine noire dans le
cours d'histoire c'est surtout par
rapport à l' esclavage et sa dénis
surtout la porte l'homme noir avait
avant et ça crée un genre de complexe de
viol devrait résider chez l'homme noir
est un complexe de supériorité chez
l'homme blanc dont il y avait toujours
cette cette dynamique qui étaient là
lors de mon secondaire et ça je peux pas
les tenir mais la bonne nouvelle selon
eux c'est que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
vivent beaucoup moins de racisme que
leurs parents dans notre génération
je me sens vraiment chanceuse parce que
ce quelqu'un peut être avoir des pensées
racistes ou travaux vont pas se
permettre de vraiment faire parce que
c'est mal vu dans la génération c j'ai
vraiment l'impression que notre
génération c'est moins pire qu'on a
envie d'être alliés par rapport à cette
cause mais on a accès aux réseaux
sociaux contrairement aux autres
générations du passé et ça nous permet
d'avoir un regard sur le monde qui est
beaucoup plus diverses
donc ça permet à des jeunes comme moi ou
à des jeunes ou à des injustices d'être
révélé au visage humain ils se
souviendront longtemps de ce printemps
2020 convaincu qu'il fera avancer les
choses
inclut tout le mouvement qui se passe en
ce moment dans le monde moi je me sens
vraiment chaleureux qu'elle soit cette
solidarité qui va avec la communauté
moi je trouve ça vraiment beau pays
j'espère que ça va continuer et pise au
delà des manifestations et c'est
vraiment d'envoi des changements c'est
d'avoir des changements dans nos
mentalités d'avoir des changements dans
notre structure lieu du mauvais et du
bon temps dans partout si c'est pas une
affaire blanc conte noir le sait
vraiment on a fait un bon compte mauvais
ti devons et tous ensemble contre les
mauvais volant